we're going to move on now to trans
rights there have been many anti-lgbtq
plus bills introduced and enacted
outlawing things like gender affirming
health care and betting kids from
playing sports do you go can I interrupt
it anytime no I I probably mad I'm
already mad okay this dude agent of the
Matrix right here complete agent let's
all pay attention real quick to the
language gender affirming Healthcare
that sounds so positive How Could You
oppose that that's what they do they
have more they have whole marketing and
branding teams Behind These propaganda
campaigns yeah they came up with like a
whole whiteboard full of terms and
that's where they landed at the end of
it very deliberate brainstorm gross okay
and then and then I'm sorry but I hate
to break it you guys couldn't play in
High School women's sports I know that's
crazy to hear but it's it's
heartbreaking and we're gonna work to
change that put your button so you
played hockey and they let the boys and
the girls play together up until the age
we're checking what age was a checking
uh like 12 12 right I was gonna say 12.
yeah when you start to grow a little
hair in your boss and you're like all
right time to time to separate right and
so they let the girls check the girls
and the boys check the boys and that was
it it's not that [ __ ] complicated no
it's really not and if you hit a girl
you would get [ __ ] you would get oh
my God the other team it's worse it's
like like I was a goalie so if you hit
the goalie it was a big deal like all my
friends you know they're Hot Heads so
they just start fights but if you hit
the girl you would you're [ __ ] yeah
that team's just going after you and
you're just a dick if you hit the girl
like who does that like even in hockey
even in high school hockey there's some
teams where the girl plays and you don't
hit the girl my name is I am a trans
woman and I am documenting my transition
publicly on Tick Tock for the world to
see when people started watching and the
numbers kept getting higher I realized
quickly how public my transition would
be of course I knew that there would be
backlash you don't know about girls you
don't know about girlhood you were a
little boy
or my spirit sorry you know what does
hurt seeing people in power in authority
figures creating laws and bills that are
actively trying to harm us trans humans
especially trans children our lives have
become political talking points
lawmakers in many states want to exclude
us from participating in sports or
getting proper Health Care some folks
want to decide where we can use the
bathroom no one should have fear of
living in a state that they call home
while being true to themselves no one
should have their lives put in danger
because of who they are inside that's
why I'm sharing my story with the world
I'm using my platform to stand up for my
community and for any of the Little
dealings that deserve a clear path to
their true identity there's active laws
coming against me are you gonna are you
gonna say any of the laws oh my God we
shouldn't be teaching little
five-year-olds about being a [ __ ]
girl about yeah about sex and switching
genders we shouldn't be teaching little
kids that oh my God that's that's that's
horrible this country's gone to [ __ ]
we're in big traveling in 10 20 years
I'm telling you I'm telling you we're
big big big trouble these Vlogs they're
racist sexist we're gonna have
transphobic we're gonna have to really
really invest now in New insane asylums
because we're gonna have so many inmates
when you can't put them all in jail
because jail isn't the place for crazy
people uh Mr President this is my 221st
day of publicly transitioning
because God doesn't love it God made him
a man oh my God God doesn't love it you
gotta find this clip somewhere or some
[ __ ] it wasn't even maybe 12 years ago
that these guys weren't even against gay
marriage oh yeah no they were they were
hard against gay marriage these guys
weren't even Pro gaming to be fair
though I'm you know me I I gotta I gotta
say I believe that people can and should
grow and change so I don't want to hold
it against them if they were against gay
marriage because I truly believe that
you can be taught and you can evolve and
and I'm glad that they changed for gay
marriage but that's the you know the
part of me that was always like more of
a moderate now apparently I'm some Ultra
Mega fascist racist homophobe according
to the internet gender affirming health
care I don't think any state or anybody
should have the right to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
you don't think anything I just think
it's wrong you know I think I was saying
before we started that my son my
deceased son used to be the Attorney
General of state of Delaware he passed
the most the broadest piece of
legislation that he as attorney general
can was able to convince the legislature
the governor to sign that dealt with uh
I can't believe this guy is the leader
of the Free World this is mind-boggling
did you know he's not the leader of the
Free World what I would really like to
know is who is isn't that a good
question that's a whole other question
look at the men in the black suits you
heard what Putin said right he said that
Trump actually had some good ideas and
then once the guys with the black the
black suits come on and show you how
[ __ ] really goes down you know those
those ideas I don't know I don't come up
Trump had a lot of good ideas
but he's in all the presidents who had
good ideas but it was different it's
different with Trump all gender
affirming capability I mean there's a
lot of you know you sometimes they try
to block you from being able to access
certain medicines being able to access
certain procedures and so on none of
that should be available I mean uh you
know no no State should be able to do
that in my view so I feel very very
strong that should be available which is
that you should have every single
solitary right including including use
of your gender identity
thank you thank you and it it feels like
Republicans have turned trans and
non-binary people into this thing to
blame society's downfall on in some ways
and this narrative is not only dangerous
to our mental health but also our
physical safety and particularly trans
women of color are being murdered at an
alarming rate more than any other group
of people what's the rate because no
that is like
I want to know why they're being
murdered worded what circumstances
suicide considered murder no I I I you
know I will give them enough credit to
say that even they are not saying
suicide is murder they counted car crash
deaths as covid deaths
I know I know I'm just look look I'm
trying to be level-headed it's not easy
I wanted to say this guy Dylan he has a
very nice and appropriate outfit for the
White House
words do black Trans women I've seen I
could I guess I'm not in the exact area
but I've seen enough that I could count
on my [ __ ] hands to be quite honest
like leaders be more effective in
advocating for us trans people and our
families and our lives and our
opportunities
I'm not being facetious when I say this
being seen with people like you
know I mean it I genuinely mean it
people fear what they don't know
they fear what they don't know
and he's right when people realize
individuals realize
this is for his day it's a good one no
but I was gonna say yeah I know I do
kind of agree with that too
that people who like like completely
shut off all trans people because like
yeah like like they're not [ __ ] the
devil like they're Norm like they're
people too like you can talk to them and
like have regular internet and we have
to remember that like we're frustrated
with the agenda and we're frustrated
with the the the
misconstrued facts and all the [ __ ]
but these are people and we have to
remember that because if they were
sitting in front of us we'd be nice to
them you are a gentleman when you're
when you're in front of people I've seen
you yeah I know and we have to remember
that and it's good to it's good to tone
it down and so I I don't agree with Joe
Biden often but when he just said people
are afraid of what they don't know it is
true he's right about that yeah not
shoving it down kid's throats if you
yeah if you have a [ __ ] trans friend
or some [ __ ] yeah it's I guess no no
right but then you can it's easy to get
angry again and go why are you teaching
this in school though why are little
kids need to understand if you want to
be trans like my view is like you want
to be trans just [ __ ] be trans nobody
cares nobody cares that's not what it is
that's not what it's about that's what I
get frustrated a bit with is because
it's not like it's just they do this
moral dilemma with everything they do it
was you're killing grandmas if you don't
want to get your coveted vaccine stay
inside wear a mask and shut your
business down now it's if you don't buy
into all this [ __ ] you want black Trans
women to die it's the same thing they go
after your morals and try to make you
feel like a bad person if you don't
agree with it and then if you do if you
do agree with it they convince you to go
after those other people because they're
the devil so it's not what they say it's
about I know what you're saying and
you're thinking from an emotional
standpoint and I get what you're saying
emotional
I get it emotional morals gotta bang
bada boom
get your brother my name is Dr Danielle
Mathison and I'm from Fort Worth Texas
as an OB GYN my job is to help women in
every medical aspect of their lives
however my schooling in Texas prevented
me from receiving the proper training in
education and Family Planning counseling
or procedures due to the state's
negative stance on the topic
now medical students studying under
these restrictions will have to resort
to filling in these gaps on their own
my colleagues and I needed to create an
off-campus after hours club that allowed
us to study the curriculum that wasn't
offered to us
there's already a shortage of OB gyns
and with the recent overturning of Roe v
Wade it's not thousands of people will
not have access to the necessary care
they need because there will be even
fewer trained medical places
abortion health care that's not
like a pregnancy I think this is such a
moral problem that a pregnancy is
considered almost like a disease that
needs to be eradicated yeah I don't know
I mean at the end of the day like I
guess I am like if I had to choose if
like there was abortions or no abortions
like I still think I have the best
stance on abortion like I'd say first
trimester and that's it like if you can
only get a a
an abortion in the first trimester and
then after that [ __ ] tough [ __ ] and I
get it they're gonna be like
women sometimes don't know
they'll call it you're getting
but women forcing women to give birth
like that's what they're missing
something yeah but even if you had to
get a pregnancy test every three every
two and a half three months come on like
then you then you know but like if
you're not if you're missing your period
educate women educate women right
there's ways to do it because I'm with
you I'm pro-choice I just don't want
this up in you like come on man all
right thank you guys for watching yeah
make sure to join and I'll smell you
later
gone
[Music]
[Music]